much maybe one option is to do something  inside for example the las vegas strip's  first permanent immersive digital art  museum it's now open it's called  perception the gallery takes guests on a  journey on the life and work of leonardo  da vinci bending your mind organizers  say the project has been long overdue  i think based on how digital is now and  presenting different formats and  highlighting the great artists of the  world we wanted to build a facility  that multi-room facility that would  really kind of highlight what's going on  in the digital world and present new  technology that it hasn't been seen  before  you can buy tickets at  visitperceptionlasvegas.com